I don't know when it happened in the
history but we've become obsessed with
the concept of having a vision right and
there's this overwhelming pressure on
entrepreneurs or any of us for that
matter that we all have to have a vision
people even ask us so what's your vision
you know what's your vision in your job
what kind of vision do you want to build
or follow and at the end of the day
we're not all visionaries we don't all
have big change the world kind of
visions and even if we have some sense
of it very few of us are really capable
or able of articulating that vision and
words so clearly than others could
imagine that same world that we imagine
sometimes it's just a feeling and so I
think it puts an unfair stress and an
unfair burden on all of us that we have
to have a vision I don't know I just
want to go to work and be happy and feel
like my life and my work is valuable do
I need more than that but I do believe
we have to find a vision we have to have
direction we have to have a North Star
we have to know where we're going
it doesn't have to be the direction we
set it can be the direction that
somebody else set so it's very important
for us to find a leader or find a
company or find a vision in whom we
believe so that our work is contributing
to building that so you know in the
civil rights era some may not have been
able to clearly articulate the vision
that they imagined but Martin Luther
King did and so for the rest of us we
said I'm following him I'm following
that vision that's the vision I believe
in and that's the point we should all
find a vision that we believe in we
should find common direction and then
that vision can become ours but we don't
have to invent it and we don't have to
originate it but we absolutely have the
responsibility to find a person company
or other entity out there other person
or organization that puts into words a
vision that we absolutely believe in and
would commit our blood and sweat and
tears to help build if we do not have
that fire in our belly the way we go
about igniting it is not actually to set
out on a journey of self-discovery and
do everything by ourselves but rather to
ask for
the whole point is that we are better
together I I sort of joke about the fact
that there's an entire section in the
book shop called self-help but there's
no section in the bookshop called help
others at the end of the day it's not
about how I can find the job of my
dreams the it's the question is how can
I help my friends find a career of
endless fulfillment it's not about how I
can lose 10 pounds it's how can I help
my friend that somebody I love live a
healthy lifestyle and the amazing thing
is is that when we're willing to ask for
help or when we're willing to set
ourselves out there to help others that
in itself helps us solve our own
problems so the irony is is the way to
ignite the fire in our bellies is to
help others ignite the fire in theirs
and in so doing we will find the thing
that excites us people often ask me for
good examples of vision you know and I
don't believe vision should be something
that is if the real it shouldn't be
something that lives in our imaginations
I believe visions and positionings or
whatever you wanna call I like to call
it the why and it's why we get out of
bed every morning it's why our
organization exists and one of my
favorite expressions of the Y is the
Declaration of Independence
you know why does America exist well we
actually declared it we actually
declared why we needed our own country
why we needed to separate from Great
Britain and we said because we had a
simple belief we believed that all men
were created equal that every single one
of us was entitled endowed with these
unalienable rights amongst which include
life and liberty in the pursuit of
happiness in other words a North Star
was set for this country and when we are
at our natural best we were working hard
to provide equality for all women
suffrage civil rights gay gay rights you
know the ability for everybody to go to
school the ability for everybody every
child have a doctor this is what when we
are at our natural best when we're
trying to figure it out none of the
systems are perfect but my goodness when
we try hard we're trying to advance the
Equality of all that is when America is
actually America and we know that to be
the case because it's not up for debate
it's because it was written down for us
and so great organizations they should
also declare why
need them to exist because it certainly
ain't in their product because none of
them have a product that's that special
that we have to have it we can't get it
from someone else and even if they did
it's temporary and that's the point the
product ain't it
it's the Declaration it's the reason why
we need you to exist it's your idealism
and your ambition for the world in which
you operate that you hope to advance
Thomas Jefferson said himself the
Declaration of Independence the
statement that he had was for the whole
world but America would take it upon
themselves to lead to try to be the
experiment so too should be the visions
of companies the visions that we have
should be for every company for everyone
but we will take it upon ourselves to
make our organization the example of
what great looks like I love the
declaration independence and it is
written in such a perfect form too it
doesn't start by complaining it starts
by idealizing and then it gets into all
of the things that are in the way of the
of this ideal and that's what we set out
to overcome